arrêter n'était pas un immeuble occupé
bobaloo consultive sont si nous sommes equi
partout où c'était un
agent séducteur Aoyama / c'est sympa hein ben
les films pas pour la télé mais je pense que
celui-ci peut être très sympa aussi
para pacem para pas être près des facilités
cependant, nous avons besoin d'un mantra de coriandre
très populaire juste externe Je veux que le
monde soit un optométriste des articles
inclus ainsi que des contrats du tout mais par
programme Oprah je veux un professeur de Bible que vous
êtes ou le dites à tout le monde à Oliver monsieur
s'il vous plaît ne faites pas d'allergies
à propos de la vitesse d'écoulement ultra élevée d'accord d'
accord
je pense que les gens sur lesquels nous allons là
-bas veulent aussi être parce que quelque chose je
pense que cette chose est là-dedans nous
ne savons pas comment tout voir
du haut
je ne pense pas  tu vas qu'est-ce que tu
penses que ça peut être une belle boîte qu'elle
te parle j'allais être très court
ici par ici tu baises pour que tu n'es
pas je suppose que c'est ici arrête d'enregistrer
judiciaire comme tu devrais le faire  seul sur
le vélo hein maintenant  vous annulez toute occasion
sur le côté ici inscrivez-vous signifie
qu'ils vont vous mettre plus tard certains
disent que vous êtes nul ouais public ou tout d'un
coup il a dit d'accord prenons ça, restons en
dehors de ça d'accord c'est au-delà du sol
ouais d'accord arrête Raquel  obtenir beaucoup de choses de
droit parental et bonne
fille bleue je suis skipper
nous ajoutons encore à la liste là-bas dix
heures au loin environ 4
kilomètres d'accord ombre tu
descends nous allons - d'accord main gauche nous
allons emballer  sur les voies à droite, ah
merci, arrêtez d'enregistrer,
je dis allons laver tout ce que vous ressentez
Villa c'est la première zone que nous devrions
avoir disponible car
quel que soit le numérique très efficace, c'est
l'offre brüder eure, il gardera
le forfait d'Elaine - nous obtenons un  petite larme
je l'attrape à droite bonne nuit les
gens bière
je ne connais pas bien ils sont toujours ici
ici ici ok allons y et super blue
backstrom hé arrête
maintenant le dernier toujours bien pas d'accord
histoire histoire histoire sur des histoires normales somaliennes
oublié mon histoire  pas trop vite
Bokke
mais en tant que choisi, ce doit être tous les
travailleurs
Je suis surpris que mon satellite ce soit une
vraie maison
pas comme ces maisons à plein temps ou juste
les maisons saisonnières Je vais être à plein
temps ce sont des gens qui travaillent vraiment ici
Je pense que
oui, mais ils ont chacun leur légume,
arrêtez d'enregistrer le potager et je
ne sais pas si dans leur arrière-cour, c'est
facile.
tu es arrivé là
comme un vase
ouais ouais des gens
sympas j'en ai assez mais ça le
laisse ici si bon au moins trois surveillent mon
soutien-gorge